pauli alors elles sont vivantes là vous
croyez oui pour le moment elles dorment
bien gentil mais c'est les avancements
les chapelles à vous croire ces eaux là
parce que qu'est-ce qu'il va falloir
faire
eh bien il va falloir les assommer et le
tuer il entendu voilà alors fait pour
les tuer je vais être assommé on va voir
l'autre mais il faut les 1,6 et d'un
taux de tours voilà il faut exercer tous
les tours
bush par la chérie ne bouge pas ma
chérie on ajuste ses liens et après on
l'appelle aïe aïe aïe oui oui oui allez
le viêt-nam a plus rien à ma puce alors
là j'ai pas mâché forme
oui vous allez voir et la peur et mifid
voilà mais après ce que vous lui avez
raconté évidemment un
la voilà et bien vous allez voir on va
pas se faire comme ça y'a plus rien à ma
biche bien là là il faut pas être un
grain de tenue et et oui et c'est dix
ans il tient votre chiffre à peu près au
cas où et quand vous la somme est un
petit coup la poire
je crois que ça ne lui suffit même pas à
ma chère tu n'auras pas ma peau mais
dites moi c'est vigousse lente et
terrible
elle avait l'air de vouloir dormir et
c'est rien ça y est voilà
eh bien là c'est vous qui allez me
prendra la relève oui je la connais bien
m'a serré oui et moi je vais prendre le
couteau voilà on va tourner comme ça il
va faire tout le tour
et après ça vous rappeler ça va être
très difficile mais on va y arriver
c'est arrivé la télé et à la fin c'est
vraiment la mort je prendre aussi fort
oui oui je vois comme ça la tête va
peut-être vous offre la tête et moi
d'accord avec le chiffon 5 en dessous ça
y est je la tiens mais il faut faire la
prise c'est dégueulasse et rédige été
très facile pas du tout que je vous dise
un métier fait face à la jetée dans les
cavités bref allez allez allez allez
allez
oliver a dit ça y est ça la vie devient
le nombril
voulait pas d'un petit coup de couteau à
les méchins
ça vient ça vient ça vient à l'esprit
est là je voudrais fort la part c'est
magnifique
huit nageuses de mort à la mi saison on
a eu en fait maintenant nous allons chez
moi rue houdon agirait en fait pas ça
tous les jours il faut que damir aller
ça y est je vous débarque tout ça mais
qu'est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant et bien maintenant on va la
soupçonner la carène vivre et on va
faire notre maintenance
bon alors première opération l'a
tronçonné mâcon saône et loire lui
couper la tête tout à fait là là dans la
coupe
un morceau la revoilà ma belle tu ne
reverras plus voilà et puis ensuite on
me l'a videra bien entendu oui et puis
regardez si les frères et ses pairs vous
l'aviez simplement parce qu'on doit de
bien sûr que oui et sortir les gars vous
êtes débarrassé de votre chiffre mais je
les ai reçus merci machine c'est bien
travailler voilà très bien on a vu de
celle là non on ne vend pas n'est pas là
il est là cet enfant comme je dis tu
souffres oui enfin c'est plus facile de
faire bifteck vous est cher par résultat
est tellement bon qu'une fois de temps
en temps on veut se donner la peine de
faire ce genre de choses et vous serez
se rendra tout le monde a très bien vu
comme vous le faites